this week in Bitcoin there's four major
stories the first is the continued
Fallout from SPF and FTX Sam has gone on
a media tour and continues to get white
glove treatment he was on Good Morning
America he went to the New York Times
Summit and he's done a number of other
media appearances while some people are
trying to ask hard questions we still do
not have answers and so the big question
is why is he being treated differently
than maybe others would be if they're in
the same exact situation the second big
story is that Fidelity has introduced
Bitcoin and crypto trading for retail
investors whenever you see a
multi-trillion dollar asset manager like
Fidelity come into the market it's worth
paying attention to yes there is
sentiment that is down right now they
probably don't have as much interest for
that product as they previously would
have but just seeing them continue to
build launch products during a bear
Market is a positive sign speaking of
the bear market bitcoin's price
continues to hold strong right around 16
to 17 thousand dollars this tells me
that even with the FTX Fallout and many
other problems and bad news Bitcoin
holding strong tells us that bitcoiners
are not selling and we can see this on
chain with about 65 percent of all
Bitcoin in circulation not moving in the
last 12 months bitcoiners are convicted
for the long term and if you go back to
those Timeless investing principles of
buy-grade assets and hold them for a
long period similar to Warren Buffett or
Charlie Munger that appears to be
exactly what bitcoiners are doing last
but not least we got the jobs report
yesterday on Friday and that jobs report
came in strong there was jobs being
added across the economy and that is a
positive sign for an economy that has
been beaten all year long now the big
question is what will the Federal
Reserve do there is thought that they
may start to Pivot they may cool off on
the rate hikes and that would be bullish
for investors including stocks bonds and
Bitcoin but if they continue to get
positive news like the jobs report maybe
they won't be so quick to go ahead and
pivot I don't know what the answer is
but I do know that the macro environment
and specifically the Federal Reserve is
driving the Bitcoin Market If the Fed
continues to have a bearish Outlook
Bitcoin will go sideways or down and If
the Fed decides to Pivot my expectation
would be that Bitcoin will recover keep
paying attention to the major stories
including SPF FTX and the FED they are
in the driver's seat right now I'll see
you all next Saturday I hope these
videos are valuable for you